bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission que vous pourrez grâce à
monsieur olivier véran regarder à 22h30
en sortant du restaurant
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler des entreprises zombies
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode
de ses caches entreprises zombies fraude
au chômage partiel la crise sanitaire
liée aux qu'ovide 19 a non seulement
plombé notre économie mais elle a aussi
a mise en évidence de sombres aspects de
cette dernière
cette semaine on va donc s'intéresser
aux entreprises et aux concepts de
zombification de l'économie et pour en
parler nous serons en deuxième partie à
des missions avec pierre bentata
économiste et président du cabinet rinne
zen mais d'abord qu'est ce qu'une
entreprise zombies alors selon la
définition de l' ocde il s'agit
d'entreprises qui ne vivrait plus et qui
aurait fait faillite si les taux
d'intérêt étaient normaux ou encore
d'entreprises cotées en bourse existante
depuis plus de dix ans et dont le ratio
entre le bénéfice avant paiement des
intérêts et impôts et la charge des
intérêts qu'elles supportent est
inférieur à 1 voilà pour la définition
de la banque des règlements
internationaux des entreprises donc que
l'on maintient sous perfusion combien
sont-elles pourquoi continue-t-elle est
d'exister
éléments de réponse avec le tiroir cash
d'antoine basse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le cycle de vie d'une entreprise c'est
le même que le nôtre unis les sens une
ville et enfin la mort sauf qu'il arrive
parfois qu'une entreprise censée fermer
le rideau continue d'être maintenue en
vie sous perfusion des aides de l'état
est en pleine crise qu vide avec les 300
milliards d'euros de prêts garantis par
l'état
le risque est d'autant plus présent
avant la crise en 2017 selon une étude
de la peyrie la banque des règlements
internationaux sur 30 2006 remet dans 14
pays
les entreprises zombies représentait
déjà 15% en france selon france
stratégie c'était environ 5% seulement à
force de contracter ces fameux prêts
garantis par l'état de suspendre les
dépôts de bilan ou de préserver le
chômage partiel tout ça sur une crise
qui va durer jusqu'à on sait pas en fait
ces entreprises zombies pourrait ainsi
se multiplier à vitesse grand v en
contractant des dettes massif qu'elles
ne pourront pas rembourser ses dettes
qui puisque l'argent il prêtait sous sa
garantie reviendra donc à être réglée
par l'état où vous et moi si vous
préférez et ralentir voire empêcher un
retour à la normale
reste à l'état de faire des choix
identifier quelle entreprise il faut
sauver
et quelle entreprise il faut laisser
mourir ou cela pourrait contaminer toute
l'économie devenant ainsi son beef ye
est totalement dépendante de l'état
alors les verts on vient de le voir en
2017 sur trente-deux mille shell dans 14
pays 15 % étaient considérés comme des
entreprises zombies c'est un phénomène
qui est donc antérieure à la crise que
nous vivons actuellement
quand ont-elles commencé à proliférer
ces entreprises ont bien et qu'est ce
qui a déclenché leur apparition c'est le
fonctionnement sur la dette c'est à dire
vous avez des entreprises qui ont sait
ne sont pas rentables et
la classification qui est faite par les
états n'est pas une classification
économique c'est une classification
politique
donc on ne ferme pas parce que
politiquement ça ferait pas beau dans le
décor est donc on subventionne et on
sait très bien que jamais ces
entreprises là au final ne nous
remboursons donc c'est quelque chose qui
un début mais qui n'a jamais de fin donc
régulièrement ces entreprises là
reviennent demandé à l'état de les aider
et est aujourd'hui avec ce qui se passe
en ce moment et les mesures qui sont
prises par le gouvernement
on s'interrogeait la semaine dernière où
la semaine d'avant sur le profil de la
reprise on aura pas de reprise
donc on est en train de parler
d'entreprises ont bis qui peut être
représenté 15%
j'ai peur que la zombification soit très
accéléré ces derniers temps et qu'on est
beaucoup plus que ça à la sortie de
cette cette crise si on en sort
d'entreprises sont bi parce que
justement on essaie de 2,2 d'entretenir
des entreprises dont on sait
parfaitement qu'elle ne sont pas
solvables et en faisant quoi en leur
prêtant encore un petit peu plus
d'argent donc on sait que elles ne sont
elles ne seront toujours pas solvable et
elle ne gagneront jamais assez en tout
cas pour nous rembourser donc ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire tout simplement
que cette dette qui est mise en place ne
fera que grossir les impôts parce que au
final c'est vous qui les paierai et j'ai
concrètement à quand remonte à peu près
leur apparition et il ya toujours eu des
entreprises comme ça zombies donc
maintenant vous aviez je dirais des pays
où on les laisser tomber
et on ose on agissait pas pour les
entretenir et puis vous aviez des pays
comme la france où on se faisait une
joie à chaque fois de faire des gros
chèque pour essayer d'entretenir quelque
chose qui n'est pas viable
donc quelque chose qui n'est pas viable
et bien un moment il faut se poser la
question de savoir si c'est plus
intéressant de continuer à l'entretenir
et deux d'or d'un gouffre sans fond un
un tonneau des danaïdes si vous voulez
ou alors prendre des mesures fermes et
la société en question et prendre des
mesures la dépenser son argent
intelligemment pour reclasser les gens
pour les former et c est pour qu'ils
restent pas sur le carreau parce que de
toute façon ils iront sur le carreau
merci olivier on passe tout de suite à
la deuxième partie de cette émission
cette semaine dans ces caches où nous
sommes en liaison avec pierre bentata
précédent à du cabinet rincon et
économiste bonjour monsieur a bien même
tu as ta bienvenue je suis dans ces
caches
bonjour bonjour merci alors vous avez
entendu olivier en première partie un
pour lui c'est le fonctionnement sur la
dette qui a créé à toutes ces
entreprises à zombies vous est-ce que
est d'abord est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette analyse et comment
est ce que vous expliquer la présence de
ces entreprises ont dit oui oui je suis
tout je suis tout à fait d'accord vous
pouvez pas avoir d' entreprises zombies
concrètement même si on passe au delà au
départ on parlait de pourparlers de
zombies pour les entreprises cotées
mais aujourd'hui vous pouvez avoir
n'importe quel type d'entreprise qui
deviennent des zombies à partir du
moment où finalement elles n'ont même
pas assez d'argent pour rembourser leurs
dettes et du coup elle s'endette encore
davantage pour pouvoir simplement payer
les intérêts de leur dette
donc elles n'ont plus suffisamment de
cash de trésorerie qui entrent et elles
se retrouvent dans des situations de
surendettement où elles ne peuvent vivre
que sous perfusion alors ça ne peut pas
fonctionner si on n'a pas une économie
de dettes c'est à dire si on a pas d'une
réglementation et un gouvernement ou une
banque centrale qui mettent des taux
d'intérêt très bas et qui font marcher
la planche à billets historiquement que
quand vous demandiez tout à l'heure à
olivier historiquement ça vient du japon
c'est dans les années 80-90 qu'on a
commencé à appeler les entreprises au
japon des entreprises zombies
parce que on avait un système au japon
qui ne fonctionner que sur de la dette
avec une grosse différence
entre le japon et nos pays notamment la
france c'est que au japon la dette elle
est possédée quasiment que par les par
les japonais eux-mêmes et donc du coup
vous avez un système qui marche en
économie fermée donc il ya un problème
c'est qu'on n'arrive pas à avoir de
croissance mais par contre on n'est pas
soumis à des attaques spéculatives ou à
un surendettement des états sur les
marchés financiers internationaux ce qui
est notre cas donc ça rajoute un
problème supplémentaire ici alors pour
limiter à les dégâts liés à la crise du
côté 19 l'état a déployé tout un arsenal
de mesures pour venir en aide aux
entreprises avec notamment l'ouverture
des vannes financières une réaction
peut-être 1 messieurs et cette analyse
de patrick artus économiste en chef de
natixis malgré ce plan de sauvetage la
proportion des entreprises zombies
devrait passer de 13% avant la crise à
plus de 20% en europe et alors je cite
les entreprises qui auront été sauvées
vont devoir rembourser tôt ou tard le
monceau de dettes accumulées qu'elle
aurait contracté au risque pour celles
qui sont les moins en forme de vivoter
et de nous de voir leur survie qu'au
maintien de taux d'intérêt au voisinage
de zéro fin de citation finalement si on
comprend bien c'est un remède pire que
le mal
oui oui c'est le problème en fait c'est
que le gouvernement qui pilotait un peu
à vue et qui s'est retrouvé dans une
situation d'urgence a décidé d'ouvrir
les vannes et d'aider toutes les
entreprises
or dès le début et on en parlait dans
votre émission avant même le confinement
il ya déjà plusieurs mois
on sait que c'était obligatoire de se
retrouver dans cette situation si on
n'avait pas des entreprises des aides
aux entreprises qui était ciblé ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire dès le début
alors ça nécessitait des gros
investissements sa nécessité d'avoir une
capacité à traiter des données qui
voulait dire que le gouvernement allait
devoir travailler notamment avec des
grosses entreprises américaines
mais ce qu'il aurait fallu faire dès le
départ c'était être capable d'analyser
les bilans des entreprises pour savoir
lesquels souffrait simplement du
confinement ou de du ralentissement de
l'activité et les qu'elle était déjà en
état de deux morts avancé et ne l'ayant
pas fait maintenant se retrouve dans une
situation où le vrai problème c'est pas
tant parce qu'on parle ici de dettes
c'est pas tant le problème qu'elles
soient endettés et le problème c'est les
conséquences réelles que ça les
conséquences réelles c'est que on ne
peut plus savoir quelles sont les
entreprises qui ont souffert de la crise
parce que l'activité s'est arrêtée et
celle qui aurait dû mourir donc le
marché ne peut pas à réallouer
correctement les ressources pour ramener
l'activité vers là où les consommateurs
le veulent en fait donc on gaspille
des ressources on gaspille pas juste de
l'argent qui est imprimé on gaspille
réellement des ressources du temps de
travail des gens pour fabriquer des
choses qui servent à rien on ralentit
aussi du coup la productivité de
l'économie
le le vrai coût des entreprises zombies
c'est que ça fait baisser l'efficacité
de la production donc on perd en
productivité
on perd en croissance et tout ça fait
que on n'aura pas de on aura pas de
reprise tant que le marché par la ceni
ont aidé une réaction pas c'est aussi
surtout je suis d'accord à que ce que
vient de dire
mais c'est surtout aussi que c'est
purement c'est ça qui est amusant c'est
purement déflationniste c'est à dire que
quand vous entretenez des entreprises
qui aurait dû mourir et que donc vous
conservez des surcapacités en fait et
donc vous empêcher les prix de monter et
c'est ça qui est très drôle c'est de
voir tous ces soi disant économistes et
gouvernants ministre de l'économie qui
vous dit je comprends pas qu'avec tout
ce qu'on injecte on n'est pas
d'inflation mais il peut pas y en avoir
parce que justement on continue à faire
vivre des gens qui va des sociétés qui
aurait dû déposer le bilan depuis
longtemps et qui font une pression sur
la productivité sur les prix et qui font
que vous avez une déflation et que tout
le monde a l'air de s'étonner qu'ils
aient de la déflation banon on la crée
plus on met d'argent plus on met des
taux à zéro longtemps plus on crée une
déflation en fait et donc vous pouvez
toujours attendre
on se fixe régulièrement des objectifs à
la hausse sur l'inflation
ben je veux je peux vous dire une chose
c'est qu'ils vont attendre longtemps
pour la voir monsieur bentata est ce que
est ce que si on laissait tout
simplement mourir à ces entreprises
légales seraient ils seraient moindres
pour l'économie à court terme ça
semblerait être plus grave
mais à long terme on aurait un marché
qui est beaucoup plus sain pour le
comprendre en fait il faut bien
comprendre ce que c'est qu'un marché où
une économie de marché c'est simplement
une machine à créer de l'information des
entreprises qui coule ça veut dire que
en fait ce qu'elle faisait n'était pas
attendue où le service avait pas la
bonne qualité ou avait un prix trop
élevé par rapport à ce que voulaient les
consommateurs une entreprise qui marche
ça donne le signal à des entreprises que
c'est dans ce secteur là qu'il va
falloir commencer à mener une activité
où investir à partir du moment où il ya
plus de signaux parce que toutes les
entreprises vivote de la même façon et
que vous avez une stagnation de
l'économie où tous les secteurs en fait
finissent par être contaminée est
maintenue sous perfusion
on sait plus ce qu'il faut produire et
donc du coût à long terme le dga c'est
qu'on produit n'importe quoi on finit
par produire des choses qui servent à
rien et surtout aujourd'hui parce qu on
a fait ça de façon massive
on ne peut plus du tout savoir si une
entreprise est en bonne santé
donc quand c'est une petite boîte on
peut se dire c'est pas très grave même
si en fait il faut prendre en
considération le fait que ces petites
boîtes elles travaillent pour des
grosses oui et mais surtout on va avoir
une très mauvaise surprise quand une
grosse entreprise qu'on ne pense pas
être une zombie fini par nous dire je
suis en défaut de paiement parce que tôt
ou tard on s'aperçoit quand même que
l'entreprise qu'ils ont bibal marche pas
et quand elles vont publier leur bilan
et quand elles vont devoir déposer pour
certaines leur bilan on va avoir une
panique parce qu'on va se faire assez
bizarre on a injecté beaucoup d'argent
et finalement il ya rien qui marche
qu'est-ce qui a déjà des grosses
entreprises françaises qui peuvent être
considérées comme des entreprises
zombies
il faut il faudrait pour ça pl déjà vous
avez les banques où une bonne partie des
banques qui sont des entreprises zombies
vous avez des boîtes comme renault c'est
une entreprise on by vous avez une boîte
comme air france air france vous
remarquerez que tous les dix ans ils
viennent demander à l'état de l'argent
donc c'est bien qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
en dégager
normalement si vous voulez donc vous
êtes vous êtes vous avez plein
d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui sont des
entreprises zombies et y en a plein qui
vont le devenir qui le sont pas encore
mais qui vont le devenir avec les
mesures qu'on est en train de prendre
donc et puis petites et grosses là on
parle de sociétés qui sont des sociétés
cotées avec en plus ce qui se passe sur
les marchés si vous voulez on met des
liquidités sur les marchés les marchés
montent et quand les marchés montent et
que des titres montent les gens se
disent finalement ça va bien hein c'est
toujours la même chose
oh moi j'ai beau leur expliquer que
c'est pas c'est pas la queue qui remue
le chien mais c'est le chien qui remue
la queue et donc ne pas croire que parce
que la bourse va bien ça va bien dans
l'économie réelle aujourd'hui ça va mal
dans l'économie réelle mais ces hausses
de cours perpétuelle donne le sentiment
que finalement ça va bien quand vous
voyez des entreprises alors là c'est
pire qu'une entreprise zombies puisque
c'est une escroquerie
nicolas le la société qui était le tesla
des camions si vous voulez on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait pas de moteur dans
le camion
donc évidemment c'était une escroquerie
sauf que cette boîte là a valu des
milliards en bourse et que personne
finalement s'est penché sur la question
en se disant mais est ce qu'ils ont
réellement quelque chose et ça ça ça
vous pète à la figure plus tard tout un
coup on s'aperçoit quand on soulève le
capot on s'aperçoit qu'il ya pas de
moteur donc hélas le titre s'effondre et
là on découvre que c'est une escroquerie
mais c'est une escroquerie depuis
longtemps si vous voulez mais ce que je
vous dis ce qui se passe en bourse
aujourd'hui camoufle beaucoup les choses
messieurs avant d'aller plus loin on va
marquer une courte pause et on revient
dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au programme de ce numéro les
entreprises zombies avec pierre bentata
président du cabinet in the economist
monsieur bentata juste avant la coupure
tout vous vous évoquez pardon le fait de
repartir les entreprises ont bien en
quelque sorte empêcher l'économie de
repartir sur de bonnes bases
ça empêche justement cette destruction
créatrice aussi nécessaire à une reprise
économique
c'est ça c'est exactement ça ça empêche
ce phénomène de destruction créatrice
donc on se dit on est protégé à court
terme parce que il n'ya pas de
destruction mais ça veut dire qu'on
accepte qu'il y aura aucune création
le japon qui avait pourtant au départ
des fondamentaux de gaieté qui étaient
meilleurs que les nôtres dans les années
90 s'est retrouvé avec ce qu'on a appelé
la décennie perdue qui en fait continue
depuis 1990 et qui n'a plus d'inflation
alors qu'il mourrait dans vide en avoir
parce que ça donnerait des signaux sur
ce qui marche il ya plus de croissance
vous avez une stagnation globale de
l'économie et elle est du coup mise
vraiment sous perfusion globale d
injection monétaire
on est dans la même situation en europe
aujourd'hui particulièrement en france
et avec un problème qui a été déjà
soulevé par olivier c'est que on dépend
on a en plus une fausse information qui
vient des marchés financiers qui ont
l'air de bien fonctionner alors que on
sait que ces marchés financiers
principalement si vous regardez les
places boursières européennes elles sont
entièrement corrélé aux marchés
financiers américains particulièrement
aux smp 500 et quand vous regardez de
quoi dépend le s p500 ces variations
elles dépendent plus de l'économie
réelle
parce que eux aussi là bas ils sont vifs
y est elle ne dépend que des injections
de monnaies qui sont faites par la
banque centrale américaine par la fed ce
qui veut dire que aujourd'hui on a une
europe qui est son billet par la banque
centrale européenne les plans de relance
de nos gouvernements qui sont mal faits
parce que pas ciblé et par la politique
monétaire américaine donc on ne dépend
plus que de l'impression de que de
l'impression de billets il ya plus de
destruction créatrice on a en fait coupé
l'ailé mais les fondamentaux du marché
et donc les marchés peuvent pas
fonctionner olivier si on laisse à
mourir ces entreprises ont des queen du
chômage les coupes du chômage
il va augmenter parce que
forcément si vous fermez une société le
chômage va augmenter mais si vous voulez
si si au lieu d'aller mettre à dans le
tonneau des danaïdes si au lieu d'aller
mettre des milliards et des milliards
si vous utilisez ces milliards pour
justement former les gens les déplacés
les remettre les réengager ailleurs et
bien à ce moment là vous aurez beaucoup
moins de 2 de dommages en fait du
chômage que vous n'en avez aujourd'hui
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous continuer à
payer
finalement la la la société des graisses
petit à petit et vous avez des gens qui
sont en grande difficulté donc utilisons
cet argent intelligemment et aussi pour
rebondir
pour rebondir sur la question des dd de
la vérité des prix s'était en fait les
banques centrales en mettant les taux
d'intérêt à zéro en achetant des
obliques sur le marché les banques
centrales fausse le prix elle elle vous
met un mauvais prix un prix qui n'a rien
à voir avec la réalité un prix qui est
simplement administré par elle et à
partir du moment où vous faussez les
prix qui sont les taux d'intérêt et bien
à ce moment là la machine est un marché
financier par exemple pour déterminer le
prix est incapable de le faire et on est
incapable aujourd'hui de savoir
justement qui des entreprises sont des
entreprises zombies et qui ne l'est pas
et tout ça c'est la faute de la banque
centrale qui a cassé cette machine à
faire les prix quels marchés financiers
en les administrant sur les taux
d'intérêt et le jour où vous n'avez plus
cette banque centrale s'est terminée fin
du game c'est à dire que dans ce cas là
on reviendra une vérité des prix mais le
retour à la vérité des prix risque
d'être très saignant monsieur aventador
justement vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
le fait a de mieux cibler les
entreprises de mieux cibler les aides et
comment comment on peut s'y prendre et
ce qu on pourrait par exemple faire
appel aux banques
alors on aurait dû on aurait dû on
aurait dû faire appel davantage au big
data on aurait dû aux dépenser de
l'argent pour traiter correctement les
données comptables et essayer de les
essayer d'avoir davantage d'informations
les banques étaient les mieux placées au
départ parce que vous avez un contact
direct avec avec vos entreprises donc
vous pouvez savoir quelles sont celles
qui sont viables maintenant c'est trop
tard il fallait le faire il fallait le
faire au tout début
maintenant on à brouiller les signaux du
marché c'est trop tard il faut trouver
d'autres solutions
en revanche là où on parlait de quelles
solutions et comment éviter améliorer la
situation tout en évitant une
catastrophe en termes de destructions
d'emplois il ya une solution qui est
simple je viens de terminer un rapport
qui sera publié dans dans quelques
semaines sur le plan de relance qui a
annoncé vous avez une façon de relancer
l'économie qui est beaucoup plus saine
que ce qui est annoncé là
et qui évite ce genre de problème c'est
de baisser les impôts de production vous
voulez vous voulez permettre aux
entreprises d'avoir davantage de
davantage de marge de manoeuvre
sans les pénaliser et sans créer une
bulle qui est lié à des aides qui sont
pas ciblés vous baisser les impôts de
production en france ils sont tellement
élevé que globalement si vous revenez à
la moyenne européenne
vous créez sept cent mille emplois de
plus alors évidemment il y aura du
chômage parce que des entreprises
survivront pas avec mais c'est normal ça
veut dire que ce qu'elles font de toute
façon n'est pas rentable mais le
phénomène sera largement endiguée par
l'efficacité de cette baisse des impôts
de production pour les entreprises qui
servent à quelque chose
et ça ça vous coûte à peu près 30
milliards alors au lieu d'avoir un plan
de relance à 100 milliards de plus que
ce qu'on a déjà mis avec toutes les
hypothèses qui a derrière parce qu'on
n'est même pas sûr de vraiment à voir
cet argent baisser les impôts en france
qui sont ceux qui pénalise le plus les
entreprises
ça paraît être une solution qui est en
même temps une solution pertinente est
beaucoup plus économique est là parmi
les solutions proposées je ne réussis au
fait réagir à celles proposées par
arnaud à montebourg l'ancien ministre de
l'économie sous les rôles en il était
interrogé en sur les mesures mises en
place par le gouvernement chez nos
confrères de france inter et à propos à
des fameux apg eux les prêts garantis
par l'état voici ce qu'il a déclaré on a
besoin d'un outil complètement nouveau
au lieu de faire des prêts il faut faire
des subventions dans les toutes petites
entreprises olivier ça pourrait être une
bonne solution ça c'est quoi une
subvention excusez moi mais c'est un don
en fait c'est un don ou c'est un prêt
c'est quoi ils vont la rembourser il la
rembourse pas ça veut dire quoi
c'est c'est une grande habitude chez les
politiques de m de changer de mot de
changer de nom à des choses et il pense
que en changeant non ça va changer les
les conséquences de ce qu'ils font banon
je suis désolé une subvention c'est quoi
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne rembourse
pas donc on fait on donne de l'argent
directement à des entreprises
en effet je suis d'accord besson les
impôts sur les entreprises qui marchent
et donc qui font du résultat celles qui
sont déjà son billet
elles font pas de résultat donc vous
pouvez baisser les impôts ça va pas on
peut vous n'allez pas leur donner de
l'argent en fait en revanche
et puis et puis surtout vous en supplie
mais arrêtez de faire n'importe quoi on
va passer avant de refermer à cette
émission sur la fraude au chômage
partiel 50000 contrôles ont été
effectués à ce jour à part le ministère
du travail 442 procédures pénales sont
en cours et le montant de la fraude est
dorénavant estimé à 225 millions d'euros
plus de la moitié a déjà été récupérés
selon le ministère du travail toujours
monsieur bentata le chômage partiel
c'est aussi à ça aussi me ça participe
aussi à ce qu'on appelle la
zombification l'économie bien sûr on
l'avait d'ailleurs évoqué dans votre
édition c'était un effet qui était
évident c'était normal que ça arrive
vous avez des entreprises qui déjà
fonctionne pas bien et vous au lieu
d'essayer de cibler celles qui
fonctionnent ou d'avoir des instruments
qui incite à produire vous leur dites on
nationalise les salaires forcément c'est
c'est beaucoup plus simple vous avez
plein d'entreprises qui du coup peuvent
continuer à vivre en se disant je vais
simplement déléguer une partie d'une
partie de mes coups à l'état mais c'est
arnaud montebourg parle de subventions
pas pour le coup là c'est vraiment ça
c'est de la nationalisation totale mais
c'est pour donner simplement une image
pour que ça parle de façon non technique
c'est exactement la même chose que ce
que vous aviez en urss quand vous avez
des quatre employés dans un cinéma un
qui prenait le ticket l'autre qui vous
le rendent l autre qui le déchirent et
et le quatrième qui vous a mené dans la
salle c'est si vous payez des salaires à
rien faire de toute façon il n'ya pas de
richesse qui se crée donc c'est de la
perte est là pour le coup la perte
il faut donc qu'elles soient remboursées
tôt ou tard donc en fait c'est cesser
les citoyens qui vont payer en impôts
c'est cette fraude massive mais qu'on a
encouragé vous donner des mauvaises
incitations aux entreprises bas elle se
comporte mal c'est tout merci à beaucoup
aux pierres à vantaa d'avoir été parmi
nous dans cette émission je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste et président du
cabinet renzan olivier on continue avec
les questions cash
toutes les semaines vous le savez
olivier delamarche répond à vos
questions des questions à lui adressé
sur les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag
rt cash ou en commentaire et des vidéos
question sélectionnée cette semaine
celle de robert rollandin est ce que
l'on peut craindre dans l'avenir une
monnaie mondiale à partir d'une réunion
comme davos en janvier sur la
réinitialisation de tout ce serait bien
la première fois qu'il décide quelque
chose à davos
non non non vous avez vous avez des pays
aujourd'hui comme les états unis hier et
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne lâcheront jamais
leur suprématie que la suprématie que
leur confère le dollar donc quand à
mettre une monnaie mondiale en place il
faudrait que tout le monde s'entende
et j'ai des doutes là dessus question
est dès à présent à de gens vous parler
du problème du poids de l'état mais si
l'état n'intervient pas qui le fera mais
l'état il faut bien comprendre enfin on
a l'impression à chaque fois que les
gens parlent de l'état que c'est une
entité autre qui débarque avec un gros
chéquier mais l'état c'est vous c'est
nous c'est tout le monde l'état les
représenté par quelques rigolos mais
sinon c'est vous c'est vous qui sortez
votre chéquier
donc je pense que si si c'était direct
bien vous réfléchirez liée à deux fois
sur les interventions et comment les
faire moi je dis pas qu'il faut pas
qu'ils aient d'intervention de l'état
jeudi qu' il faut les faire de façon
intelligente or pour l'instant on ne
peut pas dire qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'intelligence là dedans
donc voilà c'est tout le lot il ya des
endroits où il ne doit pas intervenir
parce qu' il est plus nocif qu'autre
chose et il ya des endroits où il faut
qu'il intervienne bien sûr il faut
qu'ils régulent il faut qu'ils encadrent
il faut qu'ils contrôlent
il ya des choses qu'on ne peut pas
laisser faire mais mais qu'ils fassent
ça qui ne se mêlent pas tout aujourd'hui
le l'état bientôt va rentrer dans votre
chambre à coucher vous allez
à donc il vous assigne à résidence il
vous empêche d'aller dîner à partir de
22 heures
et bientôt il sera dans votre chambre à
coucher donc si vous ça ne vous dérange
pas moi ça me dérange
merci à vos courriers c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant vous pouvez à
tout moment revoir ce numéro sur notre
site internet à l'adresse rt france
points tv on se quitte avec vos derniers
mots olivier le ceci n'était pas un
nouvel épisode de walking dead mais
pourtant on a parlé de zombies tout le
temps